par le génial très sérieux cette
émission alors bougez pas parler d'une
gueule et donc est ce que vous voyez aux
anges
oui croyez qu'un petit ans d'études vous
là ici la belle a peut-être pas ici
parce que le choix je vais faire un
petit diable non ti diable je préfère
pas les fantômes vous y croyez j'écris
j'ai eu peur quand vous dormez tout seul
chez vous le soir vous avez pas peur je
m'enferme à ses chiens
c'est pas pratique est ce que vous
pourriez vous avez un destin oui croyez
en dieu mon dieu mon dieu à vous comment
il est une fleur dans les cheveux un peu
oui
vous croyez en vous je veux croire en
moi et je vous voyais la fidélité bien
sûr michelle voilà michel field a un
truc c'est que la fidélité c'est dans la
tête c'est vachement bien
vous croyez l'amour toujours non si
parce que c'est pas parce qu'on titre
quelqu'un qu'on ne l'aiment plus ou que
où qu'on oublie tout de suite avec
pascal vous téléphonez vous écrivez oui
je les ai eus au téléphone bien sûr là
je viens de rentrer d'haïti j'étais à la
semaine dernière et
oui je les ai vus mais il va m'écouter
il va bien pas de regret un peu des fois
la cei c'est cette espèce de dhombres de
pascal qui planent comme ça quand ça
peut durer toute la misère règles
salariales non c'est clair fini c'est
fini oui bien alors pourquoi il a
télépathie ben j'ai jamais eu quelqu'un
qui pouvait me faire de la vraie télé
non j'ai peur regardez moi j'ai vous
transmettre je vais vous bi mais une
pensée à regarder moi je les ai vus
travail ans et j'arrive pas la capter
ces bizuths avant ouais tiens c'est ce
que croyait à l'homéopathie
l'homéopathie pratiquement entre
guillemets sauver mon petit frère
oui j'ai dit croire vous voyez à gages
paty et sidi yahia lomé où j'ai dit vous
voyez avec des statines on aime bien sûr
voir d'accord